hey guys why do most male models
have good looking skin it's because they
have
daily skincare routines that keep
pimples away
and also keeps their skin looking fresh
and clear
now when i started my modeling career
around 13 years ago
i had no idea about skincare routines
and
products and what to do with my skin i
just had no idea
i washed my face with normal soap
and my skin did not always look great
but over the years i learned how to take
good care
of my skin and so in this video i want
to share with you my
personal skincare routine let's jump
right into it
[Music]
now just to be clear this is not a
sponsored video i don't really do that
on my channel as most of you already
know i'm just gonna show you my honest
skincare routine the products that i use
and i'm also gonna give you some good
alternatives
that you can check out now for a good
basic skincare routine you need
three or four steps at the most
first wash second shave if you are a
shaver
third exfoliate and lastly moisturize
it's actually very simple so how many
times do you have to do
your skincare routine in a day
two to three times definitely after you
wake up in the morning
and then after you work out if you work
out and then at night before you sleep
so let me quickly show you how to do it
[Music]
first you gotta clean your face wash
your face with a normal
water soluble cleanser not with a bar
of soap why well i've said it in another
video
but let me just say it again the
ingredients
that cause that soap to be in a bar form
is actually clogging your pores and you
don't want that
and then the second step when it comes
to washing your face do it with lukewarm
water not with hot water because that
just might aggravate your skin
even more and open up pores i've been
using geology for the last few months
and it works
great cheap normal drugstore products
will never be as effective
as the more higher quality products
the professional products other brands
that you can use and
trust are pc for men i've used it for
years and you can try clinique
teach handling and then if you really
want drugstore products
the best i would recommend is l'oreal
men
expert i'll add all the products for you
in the video description down below so
you can go and check it out
another tip when it comes to washing
your face don't over
do it don't be rough be gentle if you
wash your face too
long or hard it can cause dryness
irritation
and even inflammation and it weakens
your skin's ability to
fight those pimple-causing bacteria so
you don't want that and then another tip
when you dry your face
don't just rub it just pat it gently
with a towel don't rub it dry because it
will destroy your skin's elasticity
which of course will cause your skin to
start
sagging more and more as time goes on
[Music]
shave now i don't really shave that much
anymore except if i have to do it for
certain jobs then yes
i'll shave but i use a fragrance free
shaving cream my best option for shaving
cream is pc
for men you can either shave your beard
after you've washed it or
even better right after you get out of
the shower while your facial hair is
still
soft
exfoliate your skin why is it important
to exfoliate
your skin because when you exfoliate
your skin
it penetrates deeper into the skin to
unclog your
pores and to shrink it it smooths and
evens your skin tone to get that clear
skin
that you want but it's important to use
the right products here
preferably with bha in it salicylic acid
polo's choice is a great option with two
percent bha
liquid now some brands also use it
in their face wash like geology and the
amount will differ for you
because they create a unique skincare
routine the products itself the
ingredients
that fits with your needs of your skin
you go onto their website answer the
quick questions about the condition of
your skin
and then they create a unique skincare
routine
for you specifically and it ships right
to your door
moisturize now good professional brand
usually gives you a daytime moisturizer
and a nighttime moisturizer
like tj hanley pc for men and geology
the daytime moisturizer usually contains
sunscreen as well
to protect your face from the sun which
causes aging
and then the nighttime moisturizer helps
and repairs your skin
while you sleep now these are the four
steps that i
follow every single day but sometimes i
would add a
fifth step if i have dark circles under
my eyes
then all i do is just add eye cream and
i just try to get as much
quality sleep as i can and most
professional brands will also give you
an eye cream with the rest of the skin
care products
now remember i've added all the products
for you in the video description down
below
so it's just a bit easier for you to go
and check them out
now just on last advice you don't get
good skin by just
wishing for it you need to take some
time and invest into it
it's just like working out and eating
healthy
you need to make it part of your healthy
lifestyle
there's no miracle cure for having a
good looking face
so take some time take care of your face
and remember
your face is gonna represent you for the
rest
of your life so take care of it i'll see
you next video cheers guys